ANDREW HAS UNCOVERED SOME
ESPECIALLY STRONG STATEMENTS
FROM ONE OF THEM IN MINNESOTA
AND HE JOINS US NOW.
SO WHAT HAVE YOU UNCOVERED?
>> SO KIMBERLY CROCKETT IS AN
ATTORNEY AND POLITICAL ACTIVIST
WHO IS RUNNING FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE IN MINNESOTA.
SHE DOESN'T BELIEVE THE ELECTION
IN 2020 WAS LEGITIMATE.
SHE HAS CALLED DEMOCRATS CHEATS.
SHE SAID THE 2020 ELECTION WAS
RIGGED.
SHE CALLS IT THE BIG RIG.
SHE DOESN'T BELIEVE THE POST
OFFICE SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
HANDLE BALLOTS WHICH IS AN
EXTREME POSITION.
>> WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE POST
OFFICE?
>> WELL, SHE SAYS THAT THE POST
OFFICE IS UNION ENDORSED
DEMOCRATS IN GENERAL SO SHE
DOESN'T THINK THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO HANDLE BALLOTS.
WE'RE TALKING MILLIONS OF
BALLOTS EVERY YEAR.
AND ONE THING IN PARTICULAR
SHE'S BEEN PRETTY VOCAL AGAINST
IS DEMOCRATIC ATTEMPTS TO MAKE
IT EASIER TO VOTE IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
WE'VE SEEN REPUBLICANS IN A LOT
OF STATES TRYING TO TIGHTEN
THINGS UP, CUT BACK ON EARLY
VOTING, THINGS LIKE THAT.
IN ONE INSTANCE THAT WE WERE
LISTENING TO, WE INVOKED THE
SEPTEMBER 11th TERRORIST ATTACKS
WHEN TALKING ABOUT THE SUBJECT.
WE HAVE A CLIP OF THAT.
>> LET'S PLAY IT.
>> I REALLY APPRECIATE ALL YOU
DO BEING ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THIS AND HELPING ORGANIZE THIS
AND HELPING PEOPLE GET THE
INFORMATION ABOUT THESE THINGS.
>> WELL, A GOOD FRIEND AT THE
AMERICAN MAJORITY AND ALPHA NEWS
HAVE JUST DONE AN AMAZING JOB
PULLING IT TOGETHER.
WE REALIZE PEOPLE ARE
DISCOURAGED.
AND THIS IS STILL AN EXCEPTIONAL
NATION.
WE ARE STILL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND I'M BETTING ON US.
THIS IS A CHALLENGE.
MAYBE WE NEEDED A WAKE-UP CALL.
THIS IS OUR 9/11.
>> WOW.
SO WE REACHED OUT TO HER
CAMPAIGN ABOUT THIS ON TUESDAY.
THEY ASKED US FOR MORE TIME TO
LOOK OVER ALL THESE COMMENTS.
THEY DIDN'T ACTUALLY GET BACK TO
US WITH VERY MUCH.
SHE DEFENDED CALLING THE
ELECTION RIGGED.
SHE -- THEY DID NOT ADDRESS ANY
OF THE VARIOUS THINGS IN OUR
STORY.
WHAT SHE DID SAY WAS WE WEREN'T
FOCUSED ON THE ISSUES, EVEN
THOUGH ALL OF THIS IS ABOUT
VOTING RIGHTS, WHICH IS WHAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE DOES.
AND SHE SAID BASICALLY THAT THE
MEDIA WAS INTENT ON CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION.
>> WHAT'S SO IGNORANT ABOUT HER
STATEMENT IS OUR 9/11 IS OUR
9/11.
LIKE 9/11 IS HER 9/11.
THE IDEA IS LIKE OUR 9/11,
THAT'S AS IF IT HAPPENED IN SOME
OTHER COUNTRY, IT MAKES NO
SENSE.
>> IT MAKES NO SENSE.
THAT WAS WHAT REALLY WEIRD.
WOULDN'T 9/11 BE ALSO YOUR 9/11?
SO THAT WAS --
>> I UNDERSTAND SHE'S MADE SOME
PRETTY STARTLING COMMENTS ABOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN AS WELL?
>> SHE OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T LIKE
BIDEN, BUT SHE ACTUALLY THINKS
THAT THE PROGRESSIVE MOVEMENT
WING OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
WORSE.
WE CAN TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS IN
A SECOND HERE.
SHE THINKS BIDEN IS ACTUALLY
EXPENDABLE TO THESE PEOPLE AND
THEY'RE GOING TO POSSIBLY GET
RID OF HIM WHEN THE TIME IS
RIGHT.
>> LET'S PLAY THIS.
>> AFTER YOU AND DRIVE YOU OUT
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT PROGRESSIVE
ENOUGH.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT PROGRESSIVE
ENOUGH FOR THAT WING OF THE
PARTY, AND THAT'S YOUR RIFT.
THAT'S WHERE YOU TARGET.
>> RIGHT.
THEY'RE JUST GOING TO PUT A
PILLOW OVER HIS FACE WHEN THEY
GET TIRED OF HIM.
>> WHOA.
>> OH, GO QUIETLY, JOE.
>> WOW.
>> AND AN ARTICLE ON CNN.COM, WE
BARELY COVERED HER COMMENTS
HERE.
YOU CAN READ IT AND YOU CAN SEE
SOME OF THE OTHER COMMENTS SHE'S
MADE, BOTH ABOUT VOTING RIGHTS
AND ABOUT DEMOCRATS.
>> IT'S SO INTERESTING WHEN A
SOFT SPOKEN LADY WHO, YOU KNOW,
YOU MIGHT THINK, OH, SHE'S THE
PERSON WHO YOU MEET IN THE
GROCERY STORE AND SHE SEEMS SO
NICE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT BEING SMOTHERED WITH A
PILLOW.
>> YEA